lots of people are working from home
these days yeah but have you ever
considered working from
a wiener motor trend reports oscar meyer
is hiring 12 new hot doggers to drive
their wiener
fleet across america hashtag wienerfleet
hashtag wienerfleet yes your buns could
be sitting in that mobile
they're seeking recent college grads
hungry for adventure and hot dogs to
crisscross the country and meet
and greet the fans new hot dockers have
to attend hot dog
high which i would like to transfer to
uh before they get behind the weenie
wheel
and the year-long job starts in june and
you can apply
online until january 31st
so uh drew would you go ham in this
winter mobile
i have been a fan of the oscar mayer
wienermobile
since birth i am a major wienermobile
girl
i have spotted the wienermobile if
that's like when you spot the goodyear
blimp or ufo it's so exciting
it's the most amazing thing i know and i
wish they would do like uber with this
so you could like order an uber and be
like
my uber driver has a first name it's
oscar yes
i'm so excited about this we had to
mention it because you know
there's a window so get on that
application all right one quick science
news hit the daily mail reports
geologists have found a volcanic rock
that looks just like cookie monster i
can't handle it
check this out look at it that's the
outside normal rock but then you cut
into it
num num num there you go nature did that
quartz rock on the inside and cookie
joins other famous quartz rocks like
this little owl found in mexico isn't he
cute
so cute and then this the rarest of gems
a unique googly-eyed cork
the cookie monster one just does it for
me okay ross the show's almost over and
we never want it to end
so we want to leave you with a little
something to take for the road it's
doggy bag
[Music]
and today in the game show spirit i want
to talk about my favorite board game one
of my favorite board games cranium
you've seen my game closet ross i take
this really seriously
and this one is like if trivial pursuit
pictionary charades and some other games
um claymation like had a baby and it
would be cranium it's the perfect game
for people who love every game and want
to play it all at once
well and i love that there's clay
involved with this so you can pull out a
clue and then sort of make it a claim
so i did one you have to do it okay what
is it okay here's my
my skull oh sure gosh it's really cute
that's not bad right i made this before
the show so what do you think the clue
is
a muscle a bodybuilder muscle man well
darling he's a macho man is what he is
not bad right man i i really
really love um hanging out with you guys
thank you so much for taking the time
to watch the show and join us and we
hope
maybe we get to see you again tomorrow
you